book notes
[Music]
this week on book notes our guest is
harvard university professor emeritus
john kenneth galbraith
he joins us to discuss his recent book
a journey through economic time a
first-hand view
[Music]
john kenneth galbraith author of a
journey through economic time of
first-hand view
when did you first get interested in
economics
oh that was good many years ago almost
uh 60 odd years ago in
canada
i was studying agriculture
oh
how to produce better chickens better
cattle better horses
horses in those days
better fruit veg
better vegetables and this was in the
early years of the great depression
and the thoughts crossed my mind there
wasn't a hell of a lot of use producing
better crops
and better livestock if you couldn't
sell them
but the real problem of agriculture was
not efficiency and production
but the
problem of whether you could make money
after you produce the stuff
so i shifted from the technical side to
first to the study of
agricultural economic
issues and then on to economics itself
where did you live
very pardon where were you living in
canada uh southern ontario if you think
of lake erie it's like the arch over a
bridge
uh our farm my father was a livestock
breeder
uh was just at the top of the bow of
lake erie
about equal distance between
detroit and buffalo
when did you come to the united states i
came and came to the united states in
1934 the year i graduated from college i
that was in the middle of the depression
and the best offer i had really the best
offer i had was a scholarship at the
university of california
so
i had no trouble making up my mind
because
there were no alternatives
what was your degree in
uh bear pardon what was your degree my
first degree
bachelor of science in agriculture
how about the phd
that was my phd well i have no phd in
economics my phd was in agricultural
economics from the university of
california
after
california where'd you go
well i
i taught for a year at berkeley
while i was
still writing my thesis
that actually i taught
i was on the berkeley faculty but i
taught out at davis which was then part
of berkeley now a separate university
and
they i taught economics and various
other related subjects while i was
writing my thesis
who are very happy i like
california very much i still do
and
i enjoyed myself was enjoying myself
very much
i had a handsome salary of eighteen
hundred dollars a year
and one day i got a telegram from
harvard
offering me an instructorship at 2400 a
year these were unimaginable
wages at that time
well i didn't want to leave berkeley but
on the other hand there was that extra
money
so i took it into the dean
took the telegram and showed it to him
thinking he'd give me an
advance
and he looked at the
telegram looked at me and said well
galbraith you're not worth that to us
and so i moved after a year to harvard
they apparently put a somewhat more
extravagant
view took a more extravagant view of my
ability than my
my friend my old dean at berkeley
how many years did you teach at harvard
well
this is uh
something of a
anniversary for me
i began teaching at harvard 60 years ago
last week
but
i was away for several years during the
war
first in the
war matters and then as an editor of
fortune and
i taught also one year at princeton
and then
uh i was away of course in india for a
while
but uh
roughly speaking off and on
some people would think more often on
i've been teaching now 60 years at
harvard and you're the award well
60 years subject to retirement but
you're the warburg professor emeritus
that's right who is warburg
oh
warburg
paul warburg was
one of the great figures in
american economic life
he came from the famous warburg family
in europe
was the dominant member of it came to
the
family came to the united states
and he
interested himself of course
in
in financial matters he was a
noted banker but he also was
one of the founders of the federal
reserve system and one of the first
governors of the federal reserve system
when did he live
roughly from the
uh
1960s to the 1940s did you ever know him
no but his son james warburg who is
later assistant secretary of the
treasury
and also a noted public figure
was a very close friend of mine did you
ever know john maynard keynes
yes
i
in 19
1937
after the publication of the general
theory the most
well the most influential book of the
century i think even my friend milton
friedman would concede that
uh
i went to cambridge to study under
canes
that was the year he had his first heart
attack so he never showed up at the
university but we had intense discussion
with joan robinson our husband and
uh
later uh
lord as he became later lord khan
the other
people
uh younger people there we had an
intense discussion every day of keynes
and then
in the
war years i was put in charge of price
control
world war ii world war ii and one day
i started with a
staff of six people
and ended with a staff of sixteen
thousand
uh well some of those were
devoted to rationing and some
to rent control they weren't all under
my
authority
but a great many of them were
and
one day
when we were i was still getting this
mass organization underway
my secretary my very nice secretary came
in and said
there's a mr kines out
here
and i said i just can't see anybody
today you know that she said
he rather
expects me to s
to see you
and she handed me a paper that he'd
given her
the paper was on thoughts on the pig pig
fodder ratio what we call the corn hog
ratio
and who was it by
john maynard keynes
i had a
almost uh well i was i say i was almost
in the situation of a minor priest who
had refused admission to the holy father
why was he
and why is he so revered today and i was
saying he was
among his other many qualifications he
was a leading pig farmer
and that was what he and he thought i'd
made a mistake in in the
in the relation of corn
hog feed corn to the price of hogs
but
we went on from that subject to talk
about general economics
and i saw him later on in the war
because he was in washington a lot but i
i never was closely acquainted with him
uh i can't say that
what does it mean to be a keynesian
well the
broadly speaking that the
government
has a specific responsibility
for the behavior of the economy that it
doesn't work
on its own autonomous course
that the government when there's a
recession
compensates by employment by
expansion of uh
purchasing power
and in boom times
corrects by being a restraining force
that it controls the
great flow of demand into the economy
uh what is called what is what
since keynesian times has been called
the flow of aggregate demand
that was the basic idea of keynes so far
as one
so far as one can put it in a couple of
sentences how did he become
so prominent
and his name becomes so prominent
because this
uh
this was the terrible tragedy of the
great depression
uh or massive unemployment
in europe massive unemployment in the
united states
a giving
rise to the
angry
development in germany that brought
hitler and in italy that brought
mussolini
first mussolini of course
and
this
was the plausible
answer as indeed it was it was the
answer
that the government should
compensate compensate for the waste of
unemployment
and the horror of
mass unemployment
by putting people to work
even
uh or especially though
that involved borrowing and uh
and an expenditure for the employment
here
keynes came up decisively with this
proposal
at the time when people were struggling
for an answer to the problem of
depression and unemployment
he couldn't he was he was
peculiarly uniquely a man of his times
and that uh
that that thought that the government
has a positive action including the
federal reserve
is with us today
and was quite bipartisan
there are very few people
who would leave
the government out of responsibility for
depression
and even fewer people who would leave
the government out of responsibility
relieve the government of responsibility
for inflation
this book a journey through economic
time was written for what particular
reason
oh
unless i do some writing every morning i
become psychiatrically a little
disturbed uh
and
i thought it was nice to
take a
look at how
my economic ideas have developed
perhaps nicer for me than even for the
reader
and
how they what i had seen over a lifetime
uh which book is this
how many
oh there are two or three that i've
written that i've dropped out of my
syllabus
uh because i no longer take uh i no
longer quite
believe what i
once urged
but uh 25 or 30 i suppose
in
your lifetime what have you changed your
mind about in economics
oh i started out as a
rigorous 19th century
classical economist in the 1930s and
and
1940s
and
saw they
i saw the great depression problem as a
problem of monopoly
great firms constricting their outfit
constricting their employment uh
and thus causing the depression very
common view at that time
one of the books that i've dropped out
of my syllabus was one
ex
developing that thesis
and
uh in my lifetime i've
seen the importance
of once
on the one hand a critical
view the importance of taking a critical
view of some of the received wisdom of
our time of the time
and also seeing that economic economics
is in a process of constant change
and that you cannot uh
one of the errors of economics
is not in accommodating your views
to the
moment to the to the changing situation
i noticed that uh in your book you talk
about uh having known joseph schumpeter
schumpeter yeah
who was he
joseph schumpeter was uh
one of the most interesting
men
of his time
a very conservative
he
uh
was born born and brought up in austria
was an austrian scholar and
years immediately after world war ii he
was for a brief time in the austrian
finance minister
presided over the austrian inflation
developed
an enormous
sense of doubt
about the role of the state in economics
and an enormous commitment
to
the
creative power of capitalism
both views that
i
uh
would take with which i would take some
issue
but uh i wouldn't take any issue with
the fact that he was one of the most
interesting people i've ever known
now he also
he was
among other things he had a
marvelous sense of humor
uh
a
perceptive view of
of uh life
he
he once said
that uh apropos household but one
servant is worth a thousand gadgets
he um
very often
took a an extravagant
he was
he was in favor of democracy
but
he loved to say that
every spring
young americans
of the most democratically disposed
instinct
go to europe and what do they go to see
that they go to see the monuments of
past despotism
oh there were so many
things from schumpeter that
we used to meet with him every afternoon
to
he never he never argued uh with anybody
he uh he just instructed
the reason i brought it up is uh that
there were a whole group of austrians
that seemed to have had a tremendous
influence on
economists in this country
von hayek and
von mises and people like that why why
the austrians
this is a good question uh
the the old kingdom the old monarchy
had an
intensely intellectual community
in two subjects psychiatry and economics
and
they built on each other i mean the
communities built
people in the community
uh they educated each other uh
engaged in intense discussion
and then the economist
after world war ii
uh
came
to the united states
either
and as in the case of hayak and some
others
by way of
england and in rejection of the
socialist tendencies of the time in
austria which they didn't like
and
then later
in escape from hitler
and so
american public life
was enormously refreshed nor american
academic life was enormously refreshed
by this austrian migration
even though
it was by my standards most of it
much more conservative than i would be
disposed to be
you uh knew joseph kennedy
jr
yes
i knew both senior and junior
uh and you worked for jack kennedy when
he was president but how did you know uh
jack kennedy's older brother
pardon how did you know his older
brother
uh i was a
1935
i became a tutor in winter palace one of
the harvard houses
and
that was a house that
prided itself
on being
pro-irish
being
very uh very catholic in its
uh
view of
the
ethnic communities of boston
particularly the irish and that house
came
all of the members of the kennedy family
at one time or another
uh all of the mail members
and the first to come was joe
who became my one of my closest friends
uh he wasn't my tutor but uh he spent a
great deal of his time in my rooms
and i was very fond of him
and i think he rather liked me what was
the difference in your age who was older
oh i was older but why not but not by
that much i was uh
i was then in my
late 20s and he was in his late teens
and that was in 1935 this was between
1936 and 1940. when did he die
he died in ninth he died in 1944 1940
1944. and how did you know his father
the joseph kennedy jack kennedy's father
he introduced me
and his father came to the house to
visit his sons and i saw him there what
was he like
well
joe kennedy doesn't lend himself to any
brief account
he was a man of
determined ideas
great ambition
a strong family sense
uh
and uh
one should not
overlook
uh an incredible capacity for making
money but he didn't see that as the end
of life
he saw went on from that
to
see
to cherish public life
and became as you know the
head of the maritime commission
head of the the for he was the first
head of the
sec the securities exchange commission
and then went on to be ambassador to
london
you've uh i know read over the years
that uh some people think that had joe
kennedy live the son that he would have
run for president do you think that
would be the case would have been the
case well
this of course something no one can say
but he would he would certainly be a
plausible candidate for high office no
question about that he had political
sense he had political drive he had
great intelligence and he was charming
he had all the qualities that jfk had
and maybe more
uh
more uh
uh determination he was
uh
he was a much stronger scholar at
harvard than
his younger brother
uh he regarded his younger brother as
being somewhat too easygoing
when did you know that jack kennedy was
interested in you as a speechwriter or
as someone to advise him on economics
uh well i always said my relations with
him went through three stages uh when he
was congressman and senator
there would be a there was a time when
he would call up and say you know uh
how should i how should i vote on this
bill uh you would ask me
um i was very proud and i would make
suggestions
then at the next stage he would call up
and say look explain this situation to
me
but never asked me how to vote
and the third stage was we didn't call
up at all
i had a
close relationship with him
during the years when he was congressman
and senator
and that of course continued when he
became president
how did you become the ambassador to
india well i was
in 1955
i went to india in a quasi-role
semi-role semi-important role as an
advisor to the indian government i was
with the indian statistical institute
which was an arm of the indian
government
and
i was
captured
by the
indian scene and in art and in
community in general
and the indian problem
this became very much a part of my life
very much a part of my wife's life
and
one day
i had
lunch
my wife and i had lunch with
the then ambassador who
the problems we discussed were
interesting the surroundings were
beautiful
uh
the scene was exotic
and i said to kitty my wife you know if
the democrats ever get back i'm going to
bid for that job
and so by the 19 by 1960
i had already had my full
uh
round with the big leather chairs in
washington
uh seeing people
that i never wanted to see again
so i had no interest in the job in
washington
and i had let it be known that
i would be just delighted to be
ambassador to india
and the day after the election or a
couple of days after the election
kennedy called me up and said okay it's
george
uh
he uh
he had got the message along with
everybody else that was how you became
an ambassador nobody had previously
noticed my diplomatic skills
and i have to tell you nobody's noticed
them since how long did you stay there i
was there just during the canada years
and what did you learn about india
well i learned
they
i had started
in the early 1950s some 10 years earlier
i had started courses at harvard on
economics for the poor countries
economic development
i had
i had noticed
along with some others that we had a
large number of people coming to harvard
from the third world
as it was eventually to be called
who
were studying the very sophisticated
very refined
uh very theoretical
doctrines of applicable
to the united states to the developed
countries
so
with a couple of younger colleagues
we started courses
for the poor countries started courses
in economic development
assuming the very elementary stages of
economic life
and uh
from that
i became interested in what was
happening in
about puerto rico
uh what was happening in haiti and i
was for that reason that i went to india
and that was how
uh i became interested in india but i
went on from that to the whole magic of
india indian architecture
and then religion and then art
all of those things
became very much a part of my life
as you look back on some of the things
that you learned in your life about the
different
writers of of
economics
look back at karl marx
and
how does he look to you today compared
to what you thought he might be 50 years
ago
well
50 years ago or 60 years ago marx was a
much a much more central figure there's
no novelty in saying that
the great dichotomy at that time
[Music]
extending far beyond
marx's view was as between capital and
labor
the industrialist
and the working mass
now that was as i say the marxian
dialectic
which had an enormous influence far
beyond marx
it was what
widely speaking was it was the came
close to being the accepted view of
the modern society well what has
happened since
is that the uh
old fashioned capitalist has given way
to the
to management
some would go so far as to call them the
corporate bureaucracy
to that
to the ruling community
has been added lawyers accountants
journalists great television figures
the
academicians uh
journalists uh
uh a huge
uh social security and rantier class
all of which have now
political voice political power
and the other side of that dialectic of
course of the voiceless masses in our
great cities
people who are still poor
and that is the situation which marx did
not envisage
and to which marxian economics has no
relevance
also
uh not to get this into an extended
lecture
there we have since discovered
that the
comprehensive socialist system
the marxist system
as it evolved in
uh eastern europe in the
in the so in russia
and the other countries of the soviet
union
and in china uh was not a workable model
it it produced
physical results there's no question
that it made china
and particularly
the soviet union
uh gave them a great in working
industrial base
but it wasn't consistent with the
freedoms
the demands to be heard
the number of journalists the number of
television stars the number of
uh professors the number of
uh artists poets that also come into
existence with economic development
and that was something that marx did not
foresee he did not foresee
that the comprehensive socialist state
produced more people than could be kept
quiet
that it had within itself
a thrust for democratic expression
how would you define your politics today
oh
i would have no difficulty doing that
i see what is
i react to what is necessary
i would like to eschew
any formula
there are some things
where the where the government is
absolutely inevitable
uh where
we cannot get along
without
comprehensive state action
but there are many things
uh producing consumers goods producing a
wide range of entertainment producing a
wide
of cultural activity
where
the market system where
independent activity is also important
so i react pragmatically
where the market works
uh
i'm for that
for the government is necessary
for that
uh
uh i'm deeply suspicious of somebody who
says i'm in favor of privatization
or i'm deeply in favor of public
ownership i'm in favor of whatever works
in the particular case
would you call yourself a liberal
oh sure uh
i would be very happy to call the
liberal and what does that mean to you
today well as i say that that means to
me that you have a pragmatic uh attitude
toward public and toward the role of
government toward the role of the
private
of
private
economy that you don't govern yourself
by any
solidified rule what's the difference
between a liberal and a conservative in
your opinion well i would say that the
most conservatives
uh
bend inward to think of their own
interest
and
accommodate the state to their own
interest
and
uh our on the whole
uh more governed by ideology
than i would think wise as i say i
wanted to adjust to the practical
situation
when i hear some of my conservative
friends speak of the evils of government
i think they're being controlled
by
a formula rather than by specific
thought
as you look back at the the stock market
crash of 1929 and the great depression
what caused it
all the speculation that preceded it
there was
uh built into the i wrote a book on that
a great crash
uh still cells
well
what has happened is that every time the
book was about to go out of print there
comes another
ex
period of speculation
and
recession depression
and that brings the book back into
circulation again uh it's the most
permanent piece of writing i ever did
i heard
you tell the story in the book about
going into an airport
tell that story well that was how i
learned
learn to be careful about how you tie
entitled books
uh
in the old
laguardia airport
there was a
uh
a bookshop just at the bottom of the
main uh entrance before you went out to
the plains
and
the book the great crash was on the uh
bestseller list for a
few weeks a couple of weeks
and that has a bad effect my dear fellow
on the most sterling character because
you can never again
go by a store window without looking to
see whether the book is there and it
usually isn't
and so one night coming through the
laguardia terminal
i looked at the uh
bookshop
the book wasn't there and i had a little
time so
i wandered in to see if they had a copy
and after i stood around a while the
lady who was running the bookshore said
you're looking for something sir and i
was ashamed of myself god
hear that i should be going in looking
to see if a bookstore had one of my own
but i was already caught so i said well
i stumbled a bit i said i kind of forget
the author's name something like
galbraith
and then i said but but i remember the
title of the book i decided i better
come in a little strong on that
i said it's
it was called the great crash
she looked at me with tears in her eyes
and said that's not a book you could
sell in an airport
i've since learned that you must be more
careful with your titles when you write
and let's take this book right here the
latest journey through economic time
who do you write for what's the audience
out there you want to read this
oh i like that that anybody who
has an interested intelligent view of
our times uh and my times
uh
i
i i write with two things in mind i want
to be
right with my fellow economists after
all i've made my living
my life as a professional economist
so i'm
i i am careful that my economics
is
as it should be
but i have long felt that there's no
economic proposition
that can't be stated in clear
of
accessible language
so i write not only i try to be right
with my fellow economists
but i try to have
an audience of any interested
intelligent person
hope that does doesn't sound too
self-serving you write a lot about war
and the impact of war on um
you know on the economy on the country
let me just ask you a general question
about why do we have wars what what what
leads us into war in your opinion well
this is this this is the question that
may be changing
uh
until the first world war
and uh
i say in the book that the world war ii
was really the last battle of
what what had come to be called the
great war
there
since going back to the most ancient
times
national well-being
the
the
national prestige
depended on territory
uh
the more territory a country had the
more
income revenue there was
the more
people there were
uh
to be mobilized for arm strength
and so
we had an enormous sense
of territorial conflict and territorial
integrity
and that was
unquestionably
a part of the cause of war coupled with
the fact that there was a disposition in
that direction
by the land and class
a disposition to think of territorial
acquisition and territorial defense
and to think of the peasantry as
a super
superior form of livestock which could
be
used for
armed purposes
now
we have
particularly in the last 50 years in the
in the fortunate countries
the poor countries are another
subject
uh in the fortunate countries
we've had
uh
much closer much more power for the
power for the industrial and trading
community
much closer relation trading
relationships we have the multinational
corporations
we have the uh
international finance
we have
tourism close cultural relations
the landed
interest has faded into the background
and we have in consequence a much more
peaceful situation
far more peaceful
uh than we had
in the uh
uh years prior to world war
years of world war one or
so that uh
i think the
uh
tendency of the world
of the fortunate countries has been
to
on the whole
pacific
and something that uh of which in which
we should take satisfaction
i i worry about
uh
the the
the problems of economic disorder
in eastern europe and the soviet union i
think this is one of the great problems
we have i think the whole transition
there has been on the
on the whole
not well managed either from
in terms of our support for it in terms
of what is what has been done
and we still have the terrible conflict
in places like somalia rwanda
uh former yugoslavia
that
but those are poor much poorer countries
let me ask you something about the
soviet union i think that i think
economic development is a pacifi is a
great pacifying influence
if um
if the soviet union called you up and
called milton friedman up and had you
both sitting at the table and said i
want the two of you to advise
us on this country's future what would
be the difference in the way you would
apply your economic theories well i
can't speak for professor friedman
because i haven't talked to them about
this i can only speak for myself
uh i would i
and i didn't speak on this i argued for
a more gradual process
i agree i argued that sure
there are some things that could be
turned back very quickly and easily to
the private sector
restaurants uh places of entertainment
the service industry
to some extent agriculture
there are problems
uh
factories but not turn but not
do anything
uh
not to
not to trade a poorly working economic
system which was what the russians the
soviet union had for no system at all
to take
not move the great corporations back to
the private sector
until
full provision had been made for that
transfer process do you follow me
so
that this is a matter that could not
proceed by formula it had to preceded by
thought
i'm not sure
what uh
milton friedman's views would be but i
think he might be a
little more uh drastic than i would be
in your opinion why did the soviet union
fall why did the the system there not
work uh
i i would have no doubt about that uh
it was it was not that it was
uh it was a badly working economic
economic system
in one resp one important respect it
produced it was very good
at producing uh
heavy industry
transportation electricity
oil
uh
large-scale industry
on the whole it was fairly competent it
was very bad producing
the whole range of consumers goods
including food
and it never developed a design for
handling
the instability
the fluctuations the uh
uh
that are associated with
uh
clothing
with uh
consumer taste with consumer demand
those things could not be planned
but
and that was that was the economic
weakness
further than that
there's the problem matter that we've
talked about before
that this was a system which had enough
success
so that it produced a very large number
of people who demand to be heard
and
this was a system which was repressive
of the very central feature of economic
development which is the large number of
people that brings into existence
wanting voice
we talked earlier in our discussion that
you were born in canada and came over
here and went to school
did you become an american citizen oh
sure you don't become an ambassador
while you're
subject to
foreign citizenship
but
when did you make that decision
but i must tell you that in 1934
uh the second year of the new deal
i was on my way from harvard from
california to harvard and there were
several months intervene
and so i stopped to see one of my old
professors who had a high position
in washington
and
a desperate need for economist that was
the most wonderful thing about the new
deal was the shortage of economists
so he put me on the payroll to make a
study of some problems of land ownership
and
in those days
it was quite a good job
paid off my college debts
in those days
you were asked
i was not asked whether
i were a citizen or not which i wasn't
there was nothing on the civil service
forums
but i did have to go to the top floor of
the department of agriculture and affirm
that i was a democrat
uh that was required but not whether
but not the matter of citizenship what
year did you become a citizen i became a
citizen since 1937 i was
by that time politically and emotionally
and morally committed to the united
states
well where i grew up in ontario
we were in the outer fringe of the aura
of detroit
and
so
we never thought very much about the
different we regarded
broadly speaking we regarded the border
as an infringement of human liberty
you uh write in here that you used to
write speeches for adlai stevenson
that's right how did you get to know him
well
when he was nominated
in 1952
he had no staff of any sort
and two great friends of mine
uh
were recommended to him
george ball died a few months ago
a lifelong friend of mine
and arthur schlesinger jr
and
they needed an economist so they
immediately separately
called me to come to springfield to
write the economic speeches uh and
that was my first meeting with adley
what was he like
oh
it was anderlee was a wonderful person
a
good sense of humor
the delightfully kind figure
uh
intelligent
we were all devoted to hadley
what was your reaction to writing a
speech for someone like ellie stevenson
and then seeing him read it
or did he
yes
[Music]
he would
admit was always uneasy about having
people write speeches form but there was
no alternative you can't run for
president without and write your own
speeches
so he would make some changes
but
many many times
i sat
in front of the
radio
and listened to
atleast's speeches
and
bowed in
substantial agreement with something
i've written myself
could i
could i tell you a story about that
uh
this was not the 1952 campaign 1956
campaign when he ran again uh when he
ran again
i wrote the speeches on economics
but i also wrote the speeches on richard
nixon
uh
you couldn't talk aikid was sort of a
divine figure
but you could attack nixon brightly
and
addly said to me one day i want you to
write the speeches about richard nixon
because you don't have this tendency to
be fair
and
on the basis of that compliment
i wrote
several speeches
one or two speeches
not several featuring the
presumed inadequacy of richard nixon
including one that was given
in the gilmore stadium
in los angeles
which dicks
adley originally thought went too far
but then he said
well i don't think we're going to win so
we might as well tell the truth about
the man
we were not pro nixon
and
he gave the speech
which
remained uh
there were comments on it even years
after
uh
it said you roll back the stones
and you find slithering things that is
the world of richard nixon
terrible when
you mention it anymore
and uh
the crowd
it was a huge crowd received it well
and uh
a year or two later
i was of all places in moscow
uh and went
uh to a
meeting
of the soviet academy one night where a
friend of mine was being inducted in
from india
pc mahalanobis was being inducted in the
soviet academy
and there i fell into a
discussion with an old
party hack which he was
who told me that he had been invited
to
the united states
in 1956 by the eisenhower administration
to see
the election there was it was evidently
assumed that seeing a democratic
election was a good thing somebody would
some would doubt that
and i said well
you
what impressed you the most
and to my delight he said well he said
i think it was the speech that your
governor stevenson made in that big
uh football it was actually i think a
baseball then big stadium in los angeles
i had written the speech
so i said to him well what did you think
of that speech
he said well of course it wasn't a
speech you would hear in a cultured
country like ours
did you ever did you ever have a
conversation with richard nixon very
pardon did you ever talk to richard
nixon you ever have a conversation with
him no i never did he he worked for me
during the war but i was in charge of
price control and he was in charge of
writing my letters on the rationing
program and the national archives
a year or two ago dug up the letters
that he had written for me but he was
away down in the
lower reaches of the organization a very
young man and i didn't know him
you know from time to time it was
written that richard nixon was a
keynesian
well so was so was ronald reagan
ronald reagan spent profusely
to sustain the economy in the 1980s
he spent for the
on
the defense buildup
spent by my standards saw the wrong
things
but there's no question that he's had a
sense
or his people had a sense
that a big government deficit supporting
the economy
uh
was uh
uh
had a benign effect for the people it
employed
did you decide what you felt about
government and
uh how people should live and then go
find someone to support your
thesis or did you study and then decide
where you came down
oh the latter
uh
i i was
i was i don't think i was terribly
dependent on
anybody else i think i was able to make
up my mind i had teachers and i had
colleagues and i had discussion
but there was nobody that
i can think of really that i went to and
said what do you believe i must believe
it myself is that what is that what
you're asking well what i was really
getting asked who do you think
you know where did you get the views
that you have at what point in your life
and who influenced you oh i i was i'm a
product of the
whole development of economic economic
subject matter
certainly
one of the most influential books i ever
read was
adam smith's wealth of nations so it's
an enormously important book
jon stewart mill
the whole classical tradition
the first major course i had in
economics was the economics of alfred
marshall
the
great figure of neoclassical economics
and it was out of that uh
whole current of thought culminating
in some ways with keynes
that i derive my
economic thought and economic my
economic education my economic thought
such as it is
where are you living today cambridge
cambridge massachusetts at uh you do any
more teaching no i
i retired a long while ago but i
oh i give a lecture
every other week somewhere or other
we live
just adjacent to the university and
that means that harvard that you retire
do pretty much the same work for some
somewhat less money
how big a family do you have
i have three sons where are they
well i've one son who's uh a lawyer here
in washington where we're talking as a
very distinguished litigation lawyer
with uh the great firm of williamson
colony
and my middle son peter is
now
uh ambassador in croatia
uh
one of the more
uh difficult demanding
spots in the economic in the
foreign service
and my youngest son james galbraith
has followed in the family tradition
he's an economist at the university of
texas at the lbj school
how would you assess this country at
this stage in this life
well you'll have to make that question
more specific well
did it turn out in the year 1994 the way
you thought it would i mean is this is
this a
is this democracy working is government
working
yes and no
the
the growth in
income
the growth and well-being
has been enormous in my lifetime no
question about that
uh on the whole
uh
government
including the congress
are much better than when i first knew
them and
knew it
and
in the 1930s and 1940s
the
the congress is enormously better than
it was then in spite of all the
criticism that is now leveled out
on the other hand there is the problem
of our great cities
and the problem of the desolate mass of
people who
uh
live uh
without hope
in new york los angeles uh chicago
this is something which uh
which
distresses me very much i see that
as a really great problem the really
great problem of our time
what's the solution
well
uh i'm going to write a book about that
i have a book about half written called
the good society
which among
other things deals at length with the
problem of the
great cities
and
i say is just one one or two small
things
i
i put enormous emphasis on education
uh
i think we underestimate
under
uh
we underinvest
in the education
in our great cities we need a much
stronger school system
i read in the new new york times that we
might be cutting back on the education
budget well
there may be a few superfluous
bureaucrats in education but this
education is the
great escape from poverty
if we look around the world there's no
good literate population that is poor
and there's no illiterate uneducated
uneducated population that is anything
but poor
then
i am in favor of a solid safety net for
people i don't think a rich country like
ours can
allow people to
to starve or to be
to have the total absence of freedom
which comes from a total absence of
money
and i don't think we should continue to
denigrate people
who
have to live
on welfare
one of our most unkind tendencies is to
assume that they are somehow
defective
they're unfortunate but they're not
defective
i would like to see a much kinder policy
you tell us in the book that you were
born in 1908
right and since 1908 who do you think
has been the most
effective politician that you've watched
oh franklin d roosevelt no question yes
i i i was closer to kennedy my much
closer to kennedy i love john f kennedy
but uh franklin d roosevelt was
certainly the
great the polar political figure of this
century what made him so good
well
a combination of enormous political
skill
a great capacity to communicate with the
american people those fireside chats
were
just an enormous source of strength
plus an inner intelligence which
identified
he identified himself with the united
states
and was the great proponent
of
the american well-being and this went
over
the
the whole field
uh
it even extended to his vision of the
western united states is partly covered
with trees the soil the soil
conservation service
the civilian conservation corps
to some extent
civil rights but that was not his
certainly not his strongest point
[Music]
there were weaknesses there
but
they
go back to what i said before
fdr
identified himself with the republic the
republic with him
and
and
gave his whole
life to
his to the combined
force of his own personality and that of
the country
we're out of time this is what the book
looks like and you can see there the
author john kenneth galbraith a journey
through economic time of firsthand views
thank you very much sir
[Music]
for a transfer